so someone that NASA is starting fires
in space no it's not an arsonist
terrorizing the space station NASA
started this little blaze aboard the
unmanned orbital ATK Cygnus cargo
vehicle on purpose it's called the
spacecraft fire experiment seriously
that's exactly what NASA is calling it
flames on terra firma have buoyancy
which gives them that classic shape but
in microgravity flames don't rise
instead they stay blobby and spherical
and flames in space also spread
differently as in they'll just spread in
whatever direction the spacecraft's
ventilation system sends them so if you
don't know what you're doing don't light
fires in space this experiments payload
is a three foot by five foot module that
contains sensors cameras and importantly
a swatch of cloth to set a flame
appropriately enough the experiment
burned up on re-entry but during its
brief life it tackled some important
questions how materials burn in
microgravity for instance and how hot
fire gets and how fast it spreads this
will all help NASA make better fire
safety decisions in spacecraft design
and materials because let's face it if a
fire starts on a spacecraft there's not
a lot that NASA or anyone on earth can
do about it